F3: David Horowitz is a radical right winger who
in my mind is most notable for once telling Dave
Rubin in an interview that Barack Obama was a
communist. And this came up during my interview
with Dave Rubin years ago, which I'll play for
you in a little bit now. Since then, I've not
even heard the name David Horowitz mentioned,
but he resurfaced yesterday on right wing
propaganda network Newsmax to say that the W h o
the World Health Organization is also a communist
organization run by a, quote, terrorist. Let's dig
into it. And there's there's actually this allows
me to tell you some things about what's going
on at the. Let's take a look at the first clip.
M10: Is this, do you think, part and parcel of
their whole program here? You say it's just about
control. Is it really just about control?
M11: The Chinese communists,
whom the Democrats defended during the
virus who went to Biden's first acts,
was to give them half a billion dollars
to the communist organization. Who, the
World Health Organization. It's run by an actual
terrorist. That's the first thing that they did,
was to blame blame Trump for using the word China
virus. We know the president has a hammer over
him because of the criminal activities of his
son. Nancy Pelosi has huge investments in China.
She's protecting Eric Swalwell, who not
only slept with a Chinese communist spy,
but allowed her to build his his political
career. He sits on the Intelligence Committee.
These are incredibly disturbing
facts about the Democratic Party.
M10: You know, David, that if if Biden
is not going to talk about Hong Kong and
Taiwan with China, those things are off the
table. This isn't going to come up in this
meeting either. We'll have to leave it there for
now. Great to see you as always, David. We're
out of time, up against the commercial break.
F3: So David Horowitz is now 82 years old
and is one line is the same one as it was when he
was 72 and when he was 62. Anyone he doesn't like
is a communist. And just about everything that
David Horowitz said there is false. Remember
that Eric Swalwell handled the Chinese spy
situation 100 percent correctly. Eric Swalwell
was notified by authorities. This woman you had
a relationship with, what we believe was is was
a Chinese spy. And he immediately turned over all
the information. He had cooperated fully and he's
not even been accused of any wrongdoing. So Horia.
It's mentions Eric Swalwell, the interview isn't
even really about Eric Swalwell, that's just
like an aside. Here is David Horowitz years
ago saying that Barack Obama is also a communist.
M12: This is just his go to this is this is why I
say Barack Obama is a communist. He was raised
by communists. He's his whole political career
until he became the United States senator, was in
the communist left. I mean, I know these people.
If you are part of a movement
that, you know is evil,
the first thing you want to do is warn
other people about it, especially when
it's so deceptive. It talks about social justice
and all this crap. Anyway, no, well, I mean that
he hasn't. So you know what his allegiances are.
F3: And so, of course, Barack Obama is not a
communist. And back then I actually asked Dave
Rubin about this. When I said to Dave Rubin,
you know, sometimes you don't push back
when people say crazy things. And he said,
well, what's an example of that? And I
cited that exact interview with David
Horowitz. And here's how it went with Dave Rubin.
F9: Now, when David Horowitz in this specific
instance, when he said that communist thing, I was
in that particular case, I was about to stop him.
But you're right. He then did quickly. He,
like, sort of said it. It was right at the top
of the interview and he kind of flew right into
something else. And then and then the conversation
just went from there. I do remember thinking the
interview that I wanted to get back to it. But
in the course of an hour conversation, I think
that one was almost an hour and 20 minutes. You
know, sometimes something is going to get lost.
F3: The hilarious part is that Horowitz didn't
go right into something else, as Dave Ruben says,
Dave Horowitz and David Horowitz, in fact, sort of
like paused. And Dave Ruben could have asked him
about, well, what in what ways is Barack Obama
a communist? It was Ruben who chose to move on.
So David Horowitz is known for calling anything
he doesn't like communism and anybody he doesn't
like a communist. And interestingly, nobody seems
interested in confronting David Horowitz about it.
Now, I don't know if they're intimidated by him or
they like people being called communists. I don't
know. At one point, David Horowitz was actually
considered by some on the right, a conservative
intellectual, if you can imagine that. Now, to
be thorough, Horowitz also claims in the Newsmax
clip that the W h o is run by a terrorist. There
actually is some story to tell you about there.
The show is run by Tedros Adhanom. Tedros Adhanom,
I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly, who's an
Ethiopian biologist. The allegation has been made
that Tedros, when he was one of the officials
in control of the Ethiopian security services
from 2013 to 2015 was the allegations range from
indifferent to all the way up to involved in
sanctioning the killing and torturing of
Ethiopians that took place. Now, this is
an allegation that a few people have made, some
of whom have sort of questionable, questionable
credibility and questionable motives as well.
The allegations haven't determined anything.
I'm glad for it to be investigated. But to
casually called Tedros a terrorist absent anything
other than an allegation seems to be a bit
much. But they don't care. This is what they do.
So David Horowitz using a very common right wing
trope that that it seems to actually poll well,
because it's repeated so often by right wingers.
Anybody you don't like is a communist. And we
saw how effective it was leading up to the 2020
elections. We saw how frequently you would just
go, you know, our friend Michael sure would go to
Trump rallies and interview people. And they had
the vocabulary. They had the language. They very
quickly would go to Biden's a communist, Biden's
a socialist. And we know that it sticks. And
maybe that's why David Horowitz loves it so much.